il fallait donner en pâture
ultime expiatoire ce sera vide potec
[Musique]
on est déconcertée en colère en même
temps les concertée parce que c'est
complètement incohérent comme
disposition les biens et vidocq ne s'est
pas à dellys hawtai qui ont entraîné la
cinquième vague avait des trous dans la
raquette notamment due aux scolaires il
y en avait un autre lieu tous les lieux
publics recevant du public ou les passes
anitea rectifier ça qu'on vérifie en
même temps libre ils ceux qui rentrent
[Musique]
il est bon même assuré que dès le
chômage partiel aurait remis en place
totalement c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire maintenant il ya tous les
exploiteurs beaucoup de jeunes ne sont
pas salariés il ya tous les artistes
cetera il faut qu'on nous remette en
place les ailes quicks à 100%
[Musique]